the euphoria cast predicts what will  happen in season three season three you  know  no because season one i thought cassie  had her [ __ ] together right and then i  was just like slapped in the face  cassie's not  there we obviously end with maddie and  cassie's gorgeous friendship shattered  and i think maddie is figuring out like  where to go next and finding more  independence are we allowed to curse  just given the change in the in the  second season i imagine it would just be  a complete shock again do you think  there is a sober future for real i would  like to think so  we can't leave her here this can't be  the end of her story there has to be  some hope